let's talk about rigging elections
Donald Trump continues to push these
claims that the election is rigged
against him he's suggesting widespread
voter fraud the conspiracy media has
been absolutely loving it I mean they've
just been eating from Trump's hand on
this issue and I've alluded to the
inconvenient reality for Donald Trump
that this is an accusation heavily
against Republican governors and
legislators in many cases only 17 states
in the United States right now and
Washington DC the District of Columbia
have democratic-controlled electoral
system so Donald Trump uh may believe
the only way he could possibly lose is
because millions of dead people vote or
there's vote rigging going on or people
in the the states that are overseeing
the elections are somehow rigging it
against Trump but it's mostly an attack
on Republicans if that is indeed what
Donald Trump believes is going to happen
according to the National Conference of
State Legislatures 26 states have an
elected secretary of state or lieutenant
governor who oversee the elections and
seven more of those officials uh share
Authority with a commission or board
which also is either bipartisan or
sometimes republican-controlled then you
have eight more states that have a chief
official selected by a legislature or
governor the rest are run by some kind
of appointed Electoral Commission so
when you take a step back and say okay
the elections rigged so says truck
number one he's basically alleging that
elected boards bipartisan Commission's
etcetera somehow it's all rigged it's
Republicans and Democrats working
together and then in many cases you're
talking about secretaries of state or
lieutenant governor's that are
Republicans that would be the ones who
are wringing it against Trump now I know
that the Republican Party in recent days
in recent weeks has not been thrilled
with Donald Trump in many ways but to
suggest that there is a broader rigging
going on here suggests that it is really
Republic
by and large that are rigging the
election against Donald Trump in total
29 states have republican-controlled
election processes and that represents
302 electoral votes so Republican
officials alone represent more than the
necessary 270 electoral votes that are
required to be elected president of the
United States if the election is rigged
Republicans have rigged it and in fact
this election is as I've said many times
it's mostly decided and it's going to
come down to a few swing states and
those swing states are really under
Republican control i mean we're talking
about florida iowa Nevada where I'm
broadcasting from today North Carolina
Ohio these are all overseen by
Republican chief election officials even
Trump's own close advisers are trying to
push back against the rigged election
stuff Trump's national campaign co-chair
Sam Clovis told the boston herald two
days ago i have a lot of faith in the
secretaries of state across the country
when he was asked about the entire
election is rigged think Trump's on
running mate Mike Pence said a few days
ago that the campaign will accept the
results of the election and that the
only quote sense of a rigged election
came from the obvious bias in the
national media that's not rigging an
election by the way uh here are actual
ways in which elections are in a sense
rigged for using a word that Trump uses
gerrymandering is an epidemic right the
strategic drawing of congressional
districts most recently to help
Republicans by Republicans that is an
unfair rigging of the process if you
want to use that word voter suppression
by restricting early voting hours uh and
in other ways as well in traditionally
historically disproportionately
Democratic minority areas if you want to
find some kind of rigging that's a way
in which you could argue there is
rigging going on and I could go on but
bottom line what Trump is saying is
number one unproven and number two if
true mostly the fault of the Republicans
that are in shock